la chute du secteur aérien n'a pas
épargné les entreprises technologiques
québécoises up qui a développé une
application de prévision des prix des
billets d'avion l'entreprise vient
toutefois de conclure quand même
partenariat avec capital one et une
ronde de financement de 170 millions de
dollars avec nous ce soir frédérique
lalonde qui est le cofondateur et pdg
d'europe 1 bonsoir frédérique lalonde
bonsoir avec la pandémie qui a touché
l'industrie du voyage du tourisme ct kwh
à l'ampleur des effets sur vous sur vos
activités
c'est sûr que l'an dernier presque à
pareille date donc je remonte d'un an
la situation était catastrophique sion
souviens bien c'est le tout les vols ont
commencé à être interrompue il y avait à
peu près plus personne qui voyageait si
je regarde avril l'an dernier même aux
états unis
il y avait à peu près 10% de la demande
normale qui est encore en place puis
c'était presque essentiellement du
voyage d'urgence faut savoir puis ce que
je veux dire lot des tonnes beaucoup du
contexte qu'on voit là des nouvelles
les fermetures en ontario les fermetures
au québec mais aux états unis
la vaccination a progressé plus
rapidement qu'au canada ayant énormément
d et roque qui sont pleinement ouverts
dans le texas et la floride par exemple
en avoir entendu parler depuis le début
de l'année aux états unis
on a vu une augmentation de 60% de la
demande de voyages donc les recherches
pour son application après regarde
toutes ces données là et en ce moment 1
95 % de notre chiffre d'affaires et un
aux états unis
on est revenu non seulement aux chiffres
de ventes de traits pandémique mais on
n'est même plus au mois on était au
début la situation à mon avis elle
jamais été aussi différentes entre le
canada les etats-unis qui allie ans par
mois oui il s'ennuie un peu perturbant
je vais vous dire franchement quand on
voit les stades de baseball se remplir
tranquillement pas vite
vous avez réussi vous a doublé donc
votre chiffre d'affaires en 2020 par
rapport à 2010 9 comment vous
l'expliquez ça c'est la partie la plus
intéressante la première chose
évidemment la demande même pour le
voyage domestiques aux états unis 2 0
mais si on le regarde du coin du aérien
on était à peu près à
45 50 % de ce qui était normal même donc
par là tandis que bing par contre chez
oprah on a fait deux choses la première
chose c'est qu'on a diversifié
énormément en ce moment il ya à peu près
60% de nos ventes qui sont reliés à
l'aérien la balance ça va être
l'hôtel les maisons un peu comme les
rues bienne be mais aussi ses locations
de voitures qu'on a lancé l'an dernier
le point le plus important
par contre si le développement de ce
qu'on appelle aux services financiers
donc je vous donne un exemple il ya à
peu près une dizaine de services qui ont
été ajoutés dans l'application depuis
deux à temps mais le plus populaire
c'est la possibilité de geler les prix
de vols donc si vous allez sur europe 1
et vous avez une alerte qui vous dit que
c'est un bon prix mais vous n'êtes pas
prêt à faire la réservation vous pouvez
pour un tarif nominal le disons à peu
près 40 dollars
gardez ce prix jusqu'à 14 jours donc si
les tarifs augmentent ce qui est le cas
dans à peu près tous les billets d'avion
en ce moment sur la planète
vous pouvez conserver ce prix là à
barrer dans votre application sa vie et
survie cette diversification monsieur
donne plus que ça en ce moment
75% de tous nos revenus sont des
produits financiers est une des choses
qu'on a annoncé la semaine dernière
c'est qu'on va rendre ces produits là
disponibles aux autres agences de
voyages et aux autres vendeurs de
produits dont les lignes aériennes pour
est d'atténuer les effets de la pandémie
mais ce que vous décrivez là c'est la
pandémie qui vous emmener là où vous
aviez déjà commencé ce travail là d'une
bonne question on avait commencé en 2010
en 2018 et la diversification dans
l'hôtel mais aussi le développement des
services financiers
évidemment hors des points intéressants
si lorsqu'on prend risque comme c'est le
cas par exemple dans l'exemple que je
vous donnais ci arrive quelque chose de
négatif c'est à préoccuper de sa
relation to the wrestler sur notre nos
états financiers
la pandémie nous a donné ce qu'on
appelle une preuve de robustesse ça nous
a prouvé que nos modèles mathématiques
parce que tout cela fonctionne avec de
l'intelligence artificielle qui est
propriétaire
nos modèles mathématiques pourrait
survivent à un événement extrêmement
négatif et qu'on était capable même dans
les périodes où il y avait moins de
monde où il y avait beaucoup de
remboursement comme c'était le cas l'an
dernier le mettez une profitabilité
non seulement ça nous a gardés
et à flot mais c'est ce qui explique le
financement et la valeur de la compagnie
qui a ébruité que vient changer ce
financement de capital one qui devient
partenaire avec vous une ronde de
financement de 170 millions et inovia
qui dansa notamment avec patrick
pichette qu'on avait ya pas longtemps à
l'émission qu'est ce que ça change pour
vous oui absolument faire que les
investisseurs principaux sont cape town
pour ceux qui ne les connaissent
peut-être pas ils sont une banque très
importante aux etats-unis un des gros
émetteurs de cartes de crédit
goldman sachs par son bras de capital de
risque s'est joint mais c'est vrai
innovia qui est un fonds québécois à un
très très gros investissements et on a
des investisseurs qui était déjà chez
nous qui ont ajouté de l'argent le
premier point c'est que ça nous donne
une réserve si jamais par malheur les
variants a été plus résistants aux
accents au vaccin que ce qu'on croyait
on aura énormément de capitaux mais la
chose la plus importante c'est qu'apple
va devenir le fournisseur exclusif pour
tous le portail de voyages de cape town
donc tous les détenteurs de cartes de
crédit capital one dans le monde vont
maintenant avoir accès au meilleur de ce
que à part l'application offre pour
utiliser leurs points ou utiliser les
crédits qu'ils ont accumulés sur leurs 4
on va devenir le fournisseur mondial
exclusif pour la banque
l'autre point qui est important de
mentionner c'est que ce premier
partenariat est le premier dans une
série qu'on appelle à proclame donc le
nuage au point où comme je vous
mentionnais plus tôt on rend tous nos
services financiers et de réservation
disponible aux tierces parties
au cours de la prochaine année on va
évidemment mettre en ligne le portail
cape town mais on va aussi annoncer
d'autres partenariats aux états unis en
europe et même en asie où nos produits
commencent à se distribuer un peuple
très intéressant on vous suit on
continue frédérique lalonde merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh